Hey, good afternoon,
everyone, and congratulations for finding this somewhat
obscure room, possibly the furthest corner of the convention center.
I'm Todd Golub from the Broad Institute, and it's my pleasure to
chair this session together with David Solit from Memorial Sloan
Kettering on Advancing Cancer Research using International Cancer
Genome Registries. I just wanted to make a couple of
framing remarks before launching into what I think will be six
exciting talks. And that is
just a little historical perspective because we take it for
granted now that yes, of course,
it should be possible to do a meta-analysis of
cancer genome analysis across patients from
multiple cancer centers across the country and the world,
but
it didn't use to be so. When this field started
25 years ago or so,
that wasn't the standard at all. It wasn't even the standard that when you would
publish a paper that the entirety of the
data associated with that paper would be made public.
And
I'm proud to have been part of a group of early pioneers that said, "No, that needs
to be the standard, that if you publish a paper, you can't
sit on the data. You need to make it publicly available in its entirety, including
all the bits that you didn't publish on." And that was all good,
but it then became clear as cancer genome
testing entered clinical practice that a whole lot of cancer genome
sequencing was happening,
by companies, by cancer centers, and most of that wasn't
becoming available for research.
And so now, over 10 years ago,
through the vision of Charles Sawyers and the AACR leadership,
Project Genie was stood up as a way to
make it possible for leading cancer centers
to contribute the data of their patients, of course, with informed
consent,
such that today, now more than a decade later, there's
more than a quarter of a million patients
in the registry available for full analysis by the
community. And so that's awesome progress.
It's sort of hard to imagine ever going back.
But when you think about how much cancer genome sequencing is actually happening in
the world or even in the country right now, this is probably
1% or so of all the diagnostic cancer
sequencing that's happening across the world.
It's a few percent, maybe 5%, of what's
happening being done just in the United States.
So I think we, as a community, shouldn't be
satisfied with this level of data sharing.
We need to figure out how every patient that is having
their cancer genome sequence can be made available
for community research, particularly as we
move, as I believe we will, toward whole genome sequencing, where
the scale is going to matter a whole lot more.
And so we need to figure out how to make that possible.
But until we're there, lots of great science and discoveries to be made from the
data that are at hand. Most of the, not all, I think
most of the
talks today will either start with Project Genie data
analysis or use Genie as a validation for other
hypotheses.
And so let's jump right in.
The first talk will be given by Niamh Coleman from Trinity
College Dublin and talking about the
spectrum of RAS alleles seen across cancer.
Welcome.
Thank you.
You have this. Okay.
Thank you so much. Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you for the opportunity to
present on behalf of my co-author. My name is Niamh Coleman.
I'm a medical oncologist from
Trinity College in Dublin. And this afternoon, I'm going to discuss a
pan-cancer analysis of rare RAS alleles using
AACR Project Genie. I'm going to focus on their prevalence,
biological context, and implications for therapeutic development beyond
KRAS G12C.
These are my disclosures.
So activating mutations in the RAS oncogenes
we know are among the most important oncogenic drivers of cancer.
They're found in about a third of human cancers, and they remain and rightly so, a
major focus of cancer research and drug development.
And after decades of real difficulty in drugging RAS, we've had some
recent notable successes. KRAS G12C has provided
proof of concept for a direct RAS inhibition.
And in head neck cancer, HRAS mutation is being validated as a
bonafide oncogenic driver in the disease.
But these successes really only address a minority of patients.
The majority of patients we know lie beyond G12C.
So in the clinic, in reality, the majority of RAS mutant
cancers, as I mentioned, harbor the non-G12 alleles,
which remain comparatively undercharacterized and under targeted.
In KRAS, for example, we have G12D and G12V,
which exceed G12C in aggregate frequency, while NRAS and
HRAS remain comparatively undercharacterized.
This creates an important unmet biological and therapeutic need.
So while we have undoubtedly made really significant progress in RAS
targeting, we've really only addressed a fraction of the problem.
Next generation RAS strategies really require broader
biological prioritization. And to address this,
we performed a large-scale pan-cancer
analysis using AACR Project
Genie.So
I'm presenting data from version 19.
We analyzed over 271,000 tumor samples
in over 220,000 patients. As we all know, this is a
pan-cancer, multi-institutional data set.
And we focused on non G12C RAS alleles across
KRAS, NRAS, and HRAS.
We analyzed
with regards to allele prevalence by tumor lineage,
by tumor lineage distribution,
and we analyzed co-mutation architecture.
And so we hypothesized that RAS isoform are biologically distinct
rather than being interchangeable drivers.
And we aim to define the prevalence and co-mutational
signatures of rare RAS alleles,
to ultimately inform next-generation clinical trial
design.
So we began with KRAS, whereas we know the current therapeutic success is
centered largely around G12 and G12C until very recently.
So when we look across Genie,
what becomes immediately clear actually is that these so-called rare
KRAS alleles are not rare at all.
And across approximately 42,000 KRAS
altered tumors, non G12C alleles clearly dominate.
KRAS alterations were found in 16% of tumor
samples.
Importantly,
non G12C alleles dominated KRAS
disease. G12D and G12V
comprise of approximately 60% of KRAS mutations,
whereas G12C comprise roughly 16%.
The next question we asked was whether these alleles would distribute randomly
among different tumor types or whether they reflected
some distinct lineage biology.
So interestingly, what we observed is that there was clear lineage specificity.
As you can see here,
G12D and G12V were broadly distributed
across epithelial cancers such as pancreatic cancer, colorectal
cancer, and lung adenocarcinoma.
G12C and G12A were
largely lung adenocarcinoma enriched.
G12R, apologies,
wrong audience, was interestingly pancreatic cancer
restricted,
while Q61
was broadly distributed across tumor lineages including pancreatic cancer,
lung adenocarcinoma, and colorectal cancer.
So KRAS alleles, I guess, exhibited clear lineage specific biology.
We next wanted to see if this extended to the co-mutation
architectures. So we next examined co-mutation
architecture within the Bioportr platform.
And what we found was that KRAS co-mutation architecture was highly
structured. So first we observed, as you can see
here, lineage associated co-occurrence patterns
including SMAD4,
APC, CDK11, and KEAP1.
Secondly, we observed mutual exclusivity with key
pathway genes including NF1, PTEN, RB1,
EGFR, MET, and BRAF,
consistent with
or suggesting even pathway redundancy.
Altogether, these findings suggest that KRAS mutant tumors are shaped by both
tissue context but also by pathway constraints.
So we next turn to the rarer isoforms,
starting off with HRAS.
Interestingly, HRAS behaves very differently to KRAS.
HRAS mutations were rare, occurring in less than 1% of tumors.
When we looked at the type of cancers then,
interestingly,
unlike KRAS, HRAS showed selective
enrichment in specific cancer subtypes such as bladder
cancer, urothelial carcinoma, lung cancer,
melanoma, thyroid cancer, colorectal cancer, and head and neck
cancer.
And at the allele level, codon 61 mutations
dominated,
with again additional G12 and G13
variants, highlighting really a more heterogeneous
mutation spectrum. We then examined
whether this selective distribution
was accompanied by differences in the co-mutation architecture.
And what we found was looking at,
in contrast to KRAS, HRAS really showed coordinated
co-activation across multiple signaling pathways.
You can see,
as depicted here, you can see co-activation of
PI3 kinase pathways, RAS signaling, RTK signaling,
in addition to co-activation in
MET, FGFR,
alongside these MAP kinase and PI3 kinase pathway.
In addition, alterations in NOTCH1 and RD1A and cell cycle
regulators such as CDK4/6 suggest really a broader
signaling and differentiation context.
Then when ranked by effect size, HRAS co-mutations appear to really cluster
around lots of differing pathways.
Strongest signaling was being really in NOTCH1 and FGFR and
AKT1.
Altogether, this indicates that HRAS is
not a dominant pathway-defining driver, but instead operates within a more
coordinated multi-pathway signaling network.
Finally, we move to NRASUm,
NRAS
really showed a distinct distribution, again, separate from KRAS and
HRAS, with strong enrichment in melanoma and myeloid cancers,
colorectal cancer, lung cancer, and thyroid cancer.
At the allele level, as you can see on the right-hand side,
Q61 was strongly dominant, accounting for roughly
56% of NRAS mutations.
We then examined the associated co-mutation architecture.
And again, NRAS demonstrated something that was
separate and different in contrast to KRAS and HRAS,
where you can see here,
NRAS co-mutation architecture really demonstrated both pathway
redundancy
and context-dependent cooperation, where you can see
mutual exclusivity with EGFR and PI3 kinase or
PIK3CA even,
consistent with the upstream PI3 kinase pathway redundancy.
Secondly then, there is a distinct co-mutation of significant clusters here,
including gene specific for colorectal cancer and melanoma,
including CDK and 2A and TERT alterations, as well as
the broader RAS signaling modulating
genes. Altogether indicating that NRAS really operates within a
hybrid architecture rather than a single dominant model.
So in summary, our data show that RAS
isoforms are not interchangeable, but they define
distinct biological architectures with codon and
lineage-specific features.
KRAS alterations, for instance, are broadly pan-epithelial,
whereas HRAS and NRAS are enriched within
more discrete lineage-specific contexts.
We also observed clear differences in the co-mutation architecture,
KRAS being
enriched for more tumor suppressor alterations such as p53,
SEK11,
HRAS demonstrating more coordinated
multi-pathway signaling activation, including
activation of Notch, FGFR, and PI3 kinase, and NRAS
reflecting more tumor lineage-associated patterns.
These data are really consistent with preclinical hypotheses from
the Haigis group and Dana-Farber, which support the concept that RAS
isoforms are tissue-specific rather than interchangeable
drivers.
And collectively, really, these data support
co-mutation-driven combinations and lineage-tailored
strategies for next-generation RAS-targeted therapies.
So thank you for your attention. To acknowledge AHDR Project Genie and
my
collaborator, co-author, and forever mentor, Dr.
David Hauss.
Thank you, Niam, and I apologize for mispronouncing your first name.
You're good. I forgot I usually include a phonetic version.
No, problem.
Niamh
.
Questions?
I'll give you one.
So I guess when I think of rare RAS drivers, I think of the rare
ones like A146 or 117 or Q22.
Did you look at those?
I guess what you've described are true rare alleles .
I should have perhaps recontextualized the talk.
Mm-hmm.
I looked more at rare in the context of drug development and
investigation as targets.
So while these
alleles are truly rare, the true needles in the haystack, and
while included in the
database and the analysis,
the weight is thrown with the
more prevalent alleles.
Gary.
Hi, Niamh. Great talk.
Do you have the information whether the samples were taken were
pre-treatment or post-resistance?
And
do they have different distribution of alleles if it's a primary tumor versus
post-therapy?
I don't have that data, but obviously that would be
very important to know and very interesting, especially in the context of
treatment, right? Now that we're moving...
We have targeted agents in the clinic, so, the other question would be what
happens when we treat these patients with these drugs also, but I don't have
that
data. It's not included in the analysis.
Thank you.
Hi, I apologize. I was a few minutes late to your
presentation.
Did you use the entire data set for
Genie to look at your analysis, or was it sort
of filtered to one particular cohort from an institution?
I used the updated,
is it version 18 or 19? I think it's 19.
So the updated all tumor samples.
So to look
at these
alleles across tumors. So it's the whole data set, including all the institutions.
I want to say up to 18 institutions off the top of my head.
Did you find different sensitivity for different institutions'
panels? Did the results change when you looked
institution specifically?
That's an interesting concept. I haven't looked at
differences between institutions, as controversial as that might be
.
No worries. Thank you.
Maybe if I could ask one more question about the...
Your mutual exclusivity-
Mm.
... data were quite interesting. Presumably, you're only
powered to see mutual exclusivity
for relatively common mutations.So do you have a sense for
what
are we missing there, and what scale would be needed to
get the next layer of lower frequency second
mutations?
That's a great question.
So you're right in that you're limited in what you can analyze for
based on... I looked at it in terms of common drivers and
then the targets that made sense in terms of the tumor-specific pathways.
I think to address your question properly, I think it would be
prospective data is my take, perhaps.
So, in the context of these clinical trials that we're running in the RAS space
that are happening now,
in the clinic, the development of very phase clinical trials that prospectively ask
those questions, and look for changes over time in terms of
treatment.
So to aim to prospectively
look at biomarkers, enrich them in the context of clinical trials to answer the
question, I think would be the way I would my approach.
Great. Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
Okay. The next talk will be given by Gizem Efe.
I almost certainly mispronounced that also, from Columbia
University, and she's going to talk about neomorphic
P53 alleles.
Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
First of all, thank you to the selection committee and to our
co-chairs, for this session.
I'm Gizem Efe. I'm an Irving Scholar at Columbia University
Medical Center. And today, I will be talking about mutant
P53 gain-of-function activities that drive
organ-specific metastatic programs.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So as probably many of you know, P53 is a
tumor suppressor that is mutated in more than 50%
of cancer types.
And as depicted here, most of these mutations are missense
mutations, and they are located within the DNA binding
domain.
We can categorize these mutations as either DNA
contact mutations, where there are changes in the binding
affinity of
the protein to DNA,
or conformational mutations, where we see changes in the
structure of the protein, either at a local or a global level.
To study these mutations, we have
esophageal squamous cell carcinoma mouse model,
that is combining genetic and carcinogenic approaches.
So we have
mice with either a wild type null or
mutant P53, specifically R172H mutation.
And we treat these mice with a 4-NQO, which is a
common carcinogen.
And we can generate tumor cells, with either the
mutant, wild type, or null background.
And for us to generate a true isotype,
what we do is we deplete mutant
P53,
so that all the genetic background is the same.
So we generated metastatic tumor cells from this model, and
first, we conducted cheap sequencing analysis.
And here you can see the R motive analysis,
and we identified some transcription factors involving
NRF, Twist2, that's important in epithelial-mesenchymal
transition, or RelB, that is important in NF Kappa B
signaling.
And
when we did peak analysis on these primary and
metastatic tumors, as you can see here, we
identified many unique peaks in the
metastatic site that is different
in comparison to the primary tumor site with the
same genetic background.
So first, we thought maybe this is mainly because
mutant P53 expression increases
in the metastatic site. But our immuno blotting
results suggested that
the mutant P53 expression levels are similar both at the
metastatic and the primary site. So this suggested
that as the
tumor evolves to a metastatic site, mutant P53
occupies
novel loci. This
is either new genes or the same gene,
but additional loci, new sites.
And from this analysis, we
specifically focused on colony-stimulating factor 1, CSF1, that is
important in macrophage programming.
And specifically looking at the CSF1 locus here,
we identified that mutant P53 occupies the
promoter site as well as a nearby enhancer site.
And the motifs within the promoter site
showed either P63 or NF1, which can be
potential binding partners that are important in mediating
metastasis.
And similarly, we did cut and run sequencing for
H3K27 acetylation. And not surprisingly,
the tumors with the R172H mutation, with
that background, the
CSF1 locus was acetylated throughout, which wasn't the case
for the wild type P53.
Just to validate the functional role of CSF1 in
metastasis, we
thendeleted
CSF1 in the mutant p53 background, and as you can see
here, this deletion led to a significant decrease in
metastatic burden. But interestingly,
this wasn't seen with the SHP53 in p53
depleted case.
This, first of all, suggested that there is a gain of function
activity of mutant p53, but also
CSF1 did not really have a role in
reducing metastasis in this case.
And overall, we've seen that
when we integrated the RNA-seq and RNA sequencing,
there are pathways that were enriched
at the metastatic site that included
the metabolic pathways as well as cell cycling pathways.
So, so far the
previous studies focus more on a single metastatic site.
But now what we are interested in understanding
whether mutant p53 drives these
mechanisms differently in different
metastatic sites.
And here, what we did was,
using the same model, we
collected lung metastatic tumor cells as well as liver metastatic
tumor cells,
and
when we analyzed the gene expression signatures,
we identified differences, as well as some common
genes that are shared among lung
metastasis, liver metastasis, as well as primary tumor.
So this actually suggested that
metastasis progression is not uniform, and mutant
p53 has transcriptional adaptations depending on the
metastatic site.
And from this, when we did a pathway enrichment
analysis comparing the primary tumor, liver metastasis, lung
metastasis,
we've seen unique pathways that are enriched depending on the
metastatic site. So for example,
for lung metastasis, we've seen that
epithelial-mesenchymal transition or glycolysis pathways
were highly enriched, whereas Hedgehog signaling or
IL6/STAT3 signaling were highly enriched in
liver metastasis.
So again, this suggests that the metastatic
progression shows changes depending on the
site,
and
the mutant p53 mediated mechanisms are
context dependent.
So then, using ACR Genie,
we collected all the SCC cases from the
version 19,
and we wanted to do an association
between the different kinds of p53 mutations, including
frameshift, splice, nonsense, missense,
and
doing a correlation analysis with
metastasis, either the thoracic lung metastasis or
liver metastasis.
And here we've seen that actually, depending on
the metastatic site, for example, in the case of lung
metastasis,
there are stronger associations with missense p53 mutations,
and similarly, the significance reached, for example, with
spliced p53 mutations.
As expected, when we did overall survival
analysis between mutant p53 and unaltered p53,
we've seen that patients that have
mutant p53 had much worse prognosis in
compared to the
cases with unaltered p53.
Yet interestingly, when we specifically filtered for the
mutant p53 cases and
analyzed for either lung metastasis or liver
metastasis, we identified that
the cases with lung metastasis have a
significantly better prognosis in comparison to the cases with
liver metastasis.
And again, going back to our transcriptomic analysis then, where we
identified
the
lung metastatic specific pathways or liver
metastatic specific pathways,
these can be the underlying
mechanisms that leads to the differences that we see in clinical
outcomes.
So here, I guess also referencing the
previous talk, similar to KRAS mutational spectrum,
what we see is p53 has a very
diverse mutational spectrum.
And
when we
do overall survival analysis using
different hotspot p53 mutations,
here I'm using four of the hotspot p53 mutations, we
actually see that
depending on the specific variant these patients have, the
overall survival shows differences.
So for example, patients with the R175 mutation
have
a better overall survival in comparison to
R282 mutation.And then
here, after this analysis, when we did TCGA
analysis looking at the pathways enriched, comparing
between the DNA contact and
confirmational mutations,
we identified pathways that are
specifically, uniquely enriched in DNA contact
mutation significantly in comparison to confirmational
mutation.
And when we
went
back to tissue microarrays of the SCC cases that we
have at Columbia and stained specifically
for p53 structural changes, we've seen
that those changes correlate with
later stages.
So overall, these suggested that specific p53
mutations are associated with different clinical
outcomes as well as enriched molecular
pathways.
So what does this mean therapeutically?
So this suggests that mutant p53 is not
only a biomarker, or
we cannot only consider it as
either present or absent.
We can
define it as an actionable, either
mutation-specific or organ-specific therapeutic
vulnerability.
So for example, for lung versus liver
metastasis programs, we see that they are different,
which is suggesting site-specific therapeutic opportunities.
And similarly, different p53 mutations
have distinct clinical outcomes, which is
suggesting mutation-specific, mutation-stratified
therapies.
With this, overall, in summary,
what we've been working on is, we've been integrating
RNA sequencing with p53 ChIP
sequencing and cut-and-run H3K27
acetylation to understand mutant
p53 mediated mechanisms.
And
we are
validating some clinical outcomes using
publicly available sources such as AACR GENIE and
TCGA.
So what are the future directions for us?
So we are really interested in understanding, especially
focusing on hotspot p53 mutations
and how they are
driving unique
mechanistic programs
in different metastatic organ sites.
So the other direction that we are currently taking is
understanding mutant p53 mediated epigenetic
regulators that are important in
driving
metastasis, again, specifically on esophageal squamous cell
carcinoma.
And
with that, I would like to thank to my lab mates,
collaborators, and funding sources, and happy to take any
questions.
Thank you very much. Questions? Wong.
Hey. Wonderful talk. So I was just curious, I don't know too much about p53
biology, but are you saying your confirmational change or your DNA
contact
alterations, which ones more closely resemble a total
knockout of p53?
That's a great question. I don't think there is a definitive answer for
that.
Mm-hmm.
But I would say the confirmational changes are more
likely to be involved in
the loss of function.
Oh, rather than the DNA contact. I thought it would be the other way around.
So with the confirmational change, are you expecting that this might
alter its p53 deposition on the
chromatin? So the DNA contact, I would expect that you are not going to get that
much of a signal since you're perturbing its ability to bind to DNA.
But with this contact, do you think it's going to alter where it's
going to
deposit on the chromatin?
Yeah. The way I see that is, so for example, for confirmational
mutations, there are changes in the structure so that
leads to changes in the binding partners of p53.
But when it comes to DNA contact, that's mostly
the
genes that the
p53 is binding are changing, for example.
And as you said, that also has some
implications for chromatin deposition as well.
Understood. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Thank you for an excellent talk. My question is about the multiple Kaplan-Meier
curves when you were showing the variants of p53 and how there's
a different survival outcome for those variants.
Is it possible using available public data to compare that
to those patients who don't have any mutation, who just end up without targeted
therapy on chemotherapy? Is that available in the GENIE database or in any public
sources?
You mean no therapy cases?
Well, yeah, who just end up without targeted therapy, who just end up conventional
5-fluorouracil or paclitaxel, who don't have any targeted
therapy opportunities because there's no known drugable mutation.
Yeah. So well, for us, for example, the next step was
definitely
expanding this analysis. We were thinking more on
includingWild type P53 cases or some of
the non-hotspot cases or rare P53 mutations, for
example, so including those as well.
But that's definitely another direction that we can take.
Do you have an intuition about how different it would be compared to those curves
that you're showing?
I would say
that if we are talking about therapy-naive cases or the
cases that are resistant, for example.
Is that your question?
Yeah. A patient who has
cancer-positive but
no detectable
known mutation that caused the cancer.
I would imagine, if we are specifically focusing on SCC
cases,
I would expect the prognosis to be better actually, because
P53 mutations are known to be more
as driver genes for the squamous cell carcinomas.
So in that case, I think the outcomes would be better.
Thank you.
If I could ask one last quick question about your interesting CSF1
hypothesis.
I hadn't heard about a P53 to
macrophage
signaling axis. Have you shown that the metastatic phenotype is
macrophage-dependent?
So when it comes to CSF1,
there are two different mechanisms.
So one is, yes, tumor microenvironment involvement,
macrophages, but also CSF1 are signaling, especially
in our models. They also have some autocrine signaling
involved.
Okay. So you think it may be-
So what we are seeing is it's a combination of both a
tumor-intrinsic mechanism, but also a mechanism through
macrophages.
Got it. Great. Thank you very much.
Okay. The next talk will be given by Bruno Bacorni,
from the Dana-Farber and the Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center. And he's going to talk about
KMT2C mutations and their
utility in predicting platinum response.
Thank you. Good afternoon, all. Thanks for ACRO, for the
co-chairs, for the opportunity to present
our real-world evidence of KMT2C mutation as a
biomarker of sensitivity to platinum-based therapy in solid
cancers.
These are my disclosures.
So starting with the
rationale. KMT2C, or MLL3, is a histone
methyltransferase that functions as a tumor suppressor,
regulating gene expression, chromatin accessibility, and
replication fork stability. It's one of the most commonly
mutated epigenetic regulators, occurring in 6% of
all tumor types, according to the MSK Impact data.
And as you can see, some tumor types like bladder,
cervical, melanoma, and endometrial, this prevalence is even
higher, above 10%.
Now, the biological premise of the study is that
a number of groups have established that loss of
KMT2C impairs homologous
recombination-mediated double-strand break repair,
sensitizing cells to PARP inhibition.
With this biological background, we had a very
clear clinical hypothesis.
If KMT2C loss creates functional
HRD deficiency, then patients harboring
KMT2C mutation should have increased sensitivity to
platinum-based chemotherapy, and this should be
detected using real-world survival outcomes.
To test this hypothesis,
we leveraged the Tempus Lens platform.
It's a multimodal de-identified database.
We identified 143,000 patients
underwent Tempus XT DNA testing.
From that initial cohort, we isolated a platinum-based
chemotherapy subgroup with about 19,000
patients.
The primary endpoint was real-world overall survival and
progression-free survival, comparing KMT2C mutant
versus wild type, and measuring the survival from
the time of platinum initiation.
Now, to ensure that the data was robust and
reproducible, we performed an independent validation using the ACR
Project Genie.
This is our baseline characteristics of our cohort
across 143,000 patients.
We saw a prevalence of KMT2C mutation of 5.2%.
The distribution of age, sex, and race were
comparable between both groups. Most
patients in our cohort had Stage 4 cancer, and the most
common tumor types were gastrointestinal, lung, and
breast.
Now, the first interesting finding that we
saw was when we were analyzing the somatic
landscape, we saw that KMT2C deletions and loss-of-function
mutations were more prevalent than other canonical
HRD mutations like BRCA1 and 2 and PALB2,
which points that KMT2C might represent an
under-recognized source of homologous recombination
deficiency across tumor
types.Moving to the
outcomes, in the cohort of all cancer
treated with platinum-based chemotherapy, we saw that
KMT2C mutant, here represented in blue, had an
improvement in overall survival as compared to the wild type, here
represented in red.
With a difference of 19.6 months versus 16.7
months, that was statistically significant.
We also saw a benefit in progression-free survival here on the right.
Now, when we stratified those tumor types,
we noticed that this benefit was not uniform, but
concentrated in some tumor histologies.
So KMT2C mutant patients from
gastrointestinal cancers, endometrial, and head and
neck, all had improved outcomes following platinum-based
chemotherapy as compared to their wild-type
counterparts. In all of them, this was statistically significant.
However, for breast, lung, and GU
cancers, the difference did not reach statistical
significance.
The results for us were most striking for colorectal
cancer, and I want to spend a moment here because the results were
more compelling.
In the cohort of colorectal cancer patients treated with platinum-based
chemotherapy, and we had about 3,600 of them,
KMT2C mutants had a mean overall survival of
51 months compared to 25.3 months
in the wild type.
This is a doubling of the overall survival.
You can see here on the left. And on the right, the progression for
survival benefit was also very robust.
And I am a GI oncologist, and I treat colorectal cancer.
We do not have any biomarker for
platinum sensitivity in this tumor type.
Unlike other cancers like ovarian, breast,
and pancreas, where BRCA 1 and 2 mutations are more prevalent,
those mutations are very rare in colorectal cancer, and
KMT2C occurs in about 8% of
colorectal cancer, so this could be meaningful.
We were excited to saw those results in colorectal cancer, but
we wanted to challenge the data and perform a
cross-validation using another high-quality data
set, so we turned to ACR Genie for that.
We analyzed 1,500 patients with colorectal cancer
that had clinical outcomes.
In 800 of them, we had KMT2C status,
and the prevalence of KMT2C mutation was 8.5%
in that cohort. And we asked the same questions.
Was there a difference in overall survival following platinum-based
chemotherapy? But then to ACR Genie, we ask a second
question. Was there a difference in a known
platinum chemotherapy like irinotecan-based chemotherapy?
Was there a survival difference?
Our validation was positive. In the ACR Genie
cohort,
the outcomes were improved following oxaliplatin-based chemotherapy.
Patients with KMT2C mutation had better outcome as
compared to their wild type, and this benefit appeared
to be specific to platinum-based chemo.
Patients who received irinotecan-based chemotherapy had no survival
advantage, as you can see here.
And this is consistent with irinotecan acting as a
topoisomerase one inhibitor instead of inter-strand
crosslink, which depends on homologous recombination for repair.
Lastly,
we wanted to challenge the data once again, so we performed
orthogonal validation in vitro and in vivo.
So we took multiple cell lines from the cancer types
where we saw survival advantage, colorectal, head and neck,
endometrial. We performed a CRISPR knockout in all of
these models, and we treated these cells with
oxaliplatin. The knockout cells are represented here in
blue, and in all of the models we tested, we saw an
increase in sensitivity to oxaliplatin.
Lastly, we did a in vivo validation,
so we had a xenograft model of colorectal cancer, performed
a CRISPR knockout of KMT2C, and we again showed
increased sensitivity to oxaliplatin.
So together, we think this data supports the
hypothesis that KMT2C loss of function
in fact increased sensitivity to platinum across
multiple tumor types, but particularly for
colorectal cancer.
So in closing, three takeaways from this work.
Platinum sensitivity has been validated in real-world data.
KMT2C may fill a gap where other
known canonical HRD mutations are rare.
And for us, the direction of this project's very clear.
We want to validate this prospectively in the clinic
using platinum, but also PARP inhibitors as well.
Thank you for your time, and I welcome your questions. Oh, so sorry.
I would like, of course,
to
thank my collaborators at Beth Israel, the laboratory of Dr.
Wolfe, our collaborators at Tempus, and the ACR projects
with Genie to make this huge database available for us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Bruno. Questions?
I'll do a quick one. Have you looked at any whole genome or exome data?
Is there a clear signature in the KMT2D
cases, a HRD signature or some other phenotypic signature?
Not on the patients, but in the mice
studies, we are going to do that, and in the cell lines as
well.
Nice talk. I'm just wondering if you looked to see if you could also recapitulate
the lack of benefit for irinotecan in vitro and in vivo
just to-
It's a great question. We're actually doing that.
I did not have the data available to present today, but we are doing this.
This is a negative control. I didn't know if
I
was going to have enough time.
We had some negative controls in our study as well.
In the Tempus database, we did not see a survival
benefit in breast cancer patients.
Statistically, there wasn't a difference
there. And we also checked that in cell lines, so we did a
knockout of KMT2C in breast
cancer cell lines, and we did not see a difference.
So it was good to see that negative result there.
Our next steps is to do the same with irinotecan
in cell lines and in mouse models as well.
As a GI oncologist, it's very helpful. I treat colon cancer.
I give FOLFOX or FOLFIRI, which is
oxaliplatin-based, irinotecan-based, and we have nothing to guide
us who should benefit from one chemo or another.
So this could be a potential biomarker that's helpful in clinic.
Thank you. That was a nice talk. So you mentioned about the HRD
signature for KMT2C. You looked
at BRCA genes. Did you look at any HRR genes
or maybe even evaluated HRD signatures?
No. So the only
five genes that we looked at were BRCA1 and 2,
PALB2, RAD51C and D.
It was not very comprehensive,
the list of HRDs or signatures.
Did Tempus provide any HRD data to-
I think they can. We just-
Okay
... didn't look into that.
Also, a general question. You showed survival curves for
AACR GENIE. Is that part of the BPC data set or is that part
of the GENIE data set?
Which one?
The survival curves that you showed for-
I showed many.
For the GENIE data set.
The GENIE data set.
Right.
This is from the ACR.
Oh, okay. But it's not the public version, or?
Huh?
Is it the public version?
The public version.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
I have a quick question. Thank you for the talk.
Did you look at total mutation burden in addition
to KMT2C mutant or not? It's a very long gene, so it could be.
That's an amazing question.
We did, actually. And this project is ongoing.
We submitted to ASCO.
Sorry, I think we're short on time. We did. We are investigating this.
You hit the nail on the head. It's a very large
gene. KMT2C
mutant patients are
more likely to have a high tumor mutation burden.
They tend to have a better response to immunotherapy as well.
More to come,
but great question.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Great. Thank you.
Okay, so we're going to move on to the next talk.
This is Dr. Ochi. I hope I'm pronouncing it correctly.
Who's going to talk to us about some rare BRAF mutations and fusions in pancreas
cancer.
Thank you for this opportunity to
present our work today.
Let me talk about BRAF alterations in pancreatic cancer,
focusing especially on class 2, with using
two large data sets.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
As background, BRAF genomic alterations have been
identified in various tumors, and they are classified
into three classes based on
mechanism of kinase activation.
Class one, for example, V600E,
signal as a monomer, and they are important therapeutic
targets with BRAF and MEK inhibitor.
Class two signal as a dimer,
and they include in-frame
deletion, fusion, and some point mutation.
They are resistant to first-generation BRAF inhibitor.
This is because
in BRAF dimers, blocking one part
paradoxically activate another part,
and
resulting in enhanced downstream ARC signaling.
This paradoxical activation is key why class two
fundamentally require different
treatment strategy.
We have encountered class two
alterations in pancreatic cancer in clinical practice,
which led us to start this study.
Objective is to characterize the pattern and clinical
implication of BRAF genomic alterations class in pancreatic
cancer.
We used two large data sets.
First is GECAN, which is
Japan's national data center for cancer genomic medicine.
It collect and integrate
clinical and genomic information from patients
who undergo comprehensive genomic profiling tests across Japan.
And next, second, is ACR Project
Genie.These
alterations are annotated with OncoKB and
ANNOVAR Missense and classified into class I, II,
III, and unclassification according to published
literature.
Here is the overview of our study scheme.
We selected all cases with BRAF pathogen alterations,
and they are annotated for each variant,
and they are classified by literature.
Importantly, this analysis was
restricted to
only tissue-based samples.
Then
we analyzed the frequency and class distribution of BRAF alterations
across tumor types and examined the characteristics of pancreatic
cancer.
This slide shows the frequency of BRAF
gene alterations in The Cikat,
thyroid, skin, including melanoma, and bowel
shows a high
frequency in our cohort.
And in contrast,
pancreatic cancer is relatively low.
However, as I will show in the next slide, even though the overall
frequency is low, the class distribution and
subtype
is
remarkably distinctive. Furthermore, in KRAS
wild-type pancreatic cancer, BRAF alterations represent
a critically important therapeutic target.
This is a distribution of BRAF classes.
In thyroid, skin, and bowel, class I,
mainly
V600E, were the main subtype as expected.
Some tumors, such as pancreatic cancer or prostate
cancer, showed a class II dominant pattern.
Here is a distribution of BRAF class II subtypes.
Notably, inflammatory alterations are mainly seen in
almost only pancreatic cancer.
And in Cikat dataset,
N486K/P190 alteration was the most frequent class
II alteration.
In GENIE,
fusion is the most common,
but N486K/P190 alterations are mainly
seen only in pancreas, and
rare
in other solid tumors.
To highlight the specificity of
N486K/P190 alteration, we
mapped all these alterations across the
cancer type.
Eighty-two percent of all
N486K/P190 alteration
cases were pancreatic cancer.
In GENIE, 36% are pancreatic cancer.
Compared with V600E, there is a
completely different distribution of tumor types.
Next, to
confirm these findings, we compared BRAF
classes between pancreatic cancer and bowel
cancer.
Class II, including
N486K/P190 alteration and fusion,
are more frequent in pancreatic cancer.
In contrast, class I is much less
common in pancreatic cancer.
These findings confirm a fundamentally different BRAF
alteration landscape in pancreatic cancer.
We then explored the
clinical implication of BRAF classes in terms of
patient outcome.
Also, statistical significance is not reached.
Class II
tends to have worse overall survival than class I.
And we see the same trend when
we looked at only patients who don't
receive BRAF-targeted therapy.
This suggests that these class II
alterations may be associated with
poorer outcome.
In conclusion, our study reveals a unique and
clinically important BRAF genomic landscape in
pancreatic cancer.
Class II BRAF alterations, especially
inflammatory, are mainly seen
in pancreatic cancer, and
N486K/P190 alterations are represented as a
predominant subtype.
This finding highlights the therapeutic potential of targeting class II
BRAF alterations, particularly through MEK inhibitors or
novel BRAF dimer-targeting agents.
Thank you.
Okay. So open this up to any questions.
I'll start.
What is the assay used in Japan? I would have some concern that
maybe some of the older assays that are reported in GENIE might have
had a difficulty picking up this indel because the coverage might not have
been-You know, good on exon 11 of BRAF?
Is there some uniform assay used in Japan, whereas the GENIE set
had different assays that could explain the differences in the prevalence?
Thank you for your question.
In Japan,
mainly used FoundationOne.
Yes, FoundationOne, and this is linear panels.
And on the other hand,
in GENIE cohort, a variety
of preparing test
used by a variety of diversity
institution.
It may be associated with the differences
of this result.
Okay.
Is your thinking that
these different
BRAF mutations
observed in pancreas cancer,
is that mostly biological, or does it relate to the
mechanism of mutagenesis, do you think?
Thank you for your question. I don't have a
correct answer, but in my opinion,
pancreatic cancer have a 90%
KRAS-positive tumor.
In RAS pathway, a GTP bound RAS
promotes the dimerization of RAF.
And I think pancreatic
cancer is more familiar with a dimer
than monomer.
It occur this result,
I think.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you. Great.
So we're going to bring up our next speaker,
Elizabeth Martin.
Get started here.
Who's going to talk to us about leveraging Ultima Genomics
sequencing, whole genome. Come on up.
Hello.
My name is Liz Martin. I'm a senior computational associate at the Broad
Institute in Gaddy Getz's group, and I'm here today to talk about our work
leveraging Ultima Genomics PPMseq duplex whole genome sequencing
cell-free DNA assay to accurately detect clonal evolution over sequential blood
biopsies. And I'd like to thank the organizers and the AACR for giving me the
opportunity to present our work.
I have no financial relationships to disclose, and we receive funding from Ultima
Genomics.
So we know that cancer is an evolutionary disease that progresses over time,
particularly in response to treatment.
Clonal dynamics can play a large role in treatment response and disease
adaptation. Resistance mechanisms are often heterogeneous,
especially in late-stage disease, and we'd like to know how can we better
use longitudinal sampling over a treatment course to better understand these
patterns of cancer dynamics.
To this end, we've previously partnered with Dan Uhrich and the Rapid Autopsy Group
at MGH, Mass General Hospital,
to identify resistance mechanisms and the evolutionary history of a tumor at the
time of rapid autopsy. So using these 19, in this case,
tissue biopsies at end-stage disease, we've developed phylogenetic trees that
represent the history of the tumor from disease initiation all the way through to
multi-pronged resistance. In this case, as a breast cancer case, we can
see targeted resistance mechanisms such as ESR1, but also many
subclones with a high diversity and heterogeneity of different
resistance mechanisms.
But our question is: How can we reach this level of understanding premortem?
The rapid autopsy setting, these biopsies are difficult to obtain, and
also you can't adapt treatment course at this stage
of the disease.
We've also shown in previous work that liquid biopsies
can show a heterogeneous mix of resistance mechanisms as
opposed to tissue biopsies. In this case, in a colorectal cancer cohort
in which we partnered with Ryan Corcoran,
we sequenced tissue biopsies and only detected one or two
resistance alterations in about half of the cohort,
whereas in the same cohort with cell-free DNA, we detected over
three-quarters of the cohort had resistance mechanisms, and often
more than one. We found that these mutations were often in the
MAPK pathway, showing a convergence of resistance in these cases that would have
been totally missed had we only used tissue biopsies.
We'd also like to use whole genome sequencing.
So in these rapid autopsy cases, we sequenced using Illumina whole
exome. And in this case, we had a few samples here, and we built a
phylogenetic tree using the whole exome data, and we
found about six clusters, and often there were many alterations
clustered on a single branch. But when we sampled the same
samples with whole genome sequencing, we were able to really better resolve some of
these clusters. So we were able to pull these clusters out because there are so
many more mutations that we can detect that these groups of mutations can
travel together, and then we're able to identify unique driver mutations
on unique branches, and we can better track these clones over time.
So what more can we learn if we're able to pair these more informative liquid
biopsies with whole genome
sequencing? Current state-of-the-art in
cell-free DNA tracking comes in the form of a targeted panel.
These panels are often on hundreds of driver genes, or they're patient-specific,
meaning that a patient-specific panel from a
pre-sequenced tumor biopsy is used.
The problem with this is that due to the low content of
ctDNA in the tube, sometimes we can start to miss these
driver mutations, and then we miss information about all of the mutations
that are also traveling with those cancer driver genes.
In contrast, if we use Ultima Genomics' high-depth duplex
sequencing across these samples, we can use
the clones that we've already discovered in the tumor biopsies to then
track patterns of cancer dynamics over time.
We can identify these full clones that are moving, and we can also
look backwards and try to understand when these clones originally developed in
the life history of the cancer.Ultima
Genomics uses a flow-based sequencing technology that can increase the
accuracy of SNV calls. This allows for an extremely low base substitution
error rate. The error rates are more in these strings of homopolymers, which in
Ultima Genomics has come up with some tools to mitigate these error
models, including duplex sequencing technology.
So paired plus minus strand PPMseq technology additionally lowers the
sequencing rate. Both duplex strands are most on the
same bead, and so we're able to identify these
duplex molecules with a really high confidence, increasing the read
quality, even over Ultima's standard read quality, which is
high to begin with.
Additionally, we find that the molecules have a higher duplex yield,
so we're able to get more of these high-quality read calls.
And we see this in published data and in our data set as well.
So in collaboration with Ultima, we've developed our cloud-based pipeline that
we've used in many projects, including as TCGA whole genomes project.
We use the information from Ultima as to which reads are the highest quality duplex
reads, and then we call SNVs,
CNVs, purity/ploidy, and cancer cell fraction to start modeling the cancer
over time.
We also know using our model, PhyLogicNDT, that more samples and more
mutations increases its cluster resolution.
So in whole exome, we see there's a few tens of mutations and that we have high
confidence intervals in some of these clones.
But using whole genome sequencing, there can be thousands of mutations, and we can
be highly confident about which mutations are present in which clones.
We also use an MCMC algorithm to sample the space of trees, and
we can collectively come to maybe the correct
tree. And with whole genome sequencing, we can be more confident in this tree.
So in this study, we used a previously sequenced tissue and cell-free DNA set of
six breast cancer patients. We sampled the cell-free DNA over
time, and then we also have these tissue samples at time of autopsy.
Here we chose 24 of the cell-free DNA samples of the highest
tumor fraction, about 30%, to proceed with PPMseq sequencing.
And then we can use the previously sequenced autopsy and pre-mortem
cell-free DNA whole exome sequencing as a ground truth set.
So here we show we are able to reconstruct these phylogenetic trees
with the PPMseq data. This patient was an ER-positive breast cancer patient
treated with a PIK3CA inhibitor as well as a CDK4/6 inhibitor.
And we show that there are many more mutations on the branches of these clonal
trees. We also are able to identify the mutational processes
that are active along these branches.
Comparing to the whole exome sequencing, we show that we're able to
pull out some of the clusters that were not present in the whole exome
sequencing. For example, we found this P53 mutation in the whole exome,
but it was of too low of a cancer cell fraction to confidently assign to the
tree, whereas in whole genome sequencing, we're able to cluster that mutation with
another of a group of mutations, and therefore it is able to
end on the clonal tree.
In this case, in patient 1002, we see that in
cluster six, there's a large cluster of presumptive driver
genes. And in whole genome sequencing, we're able to pull these driver
genes out into their own clusters to identify the
actual dynamics of those mutations and those clusters and notice that they're
not all actually grouped together on the same clone, but rather they represent
individual sub-clones that could be growing or shrinking in response to different
therapies.
In addition, we're also able to assign mutational processes to the branches of this
tree, and we notice that this patient had a high degree of APOBEC mutagenesis.
And then we can also compare the trees that we built with the PPMseq to
the full trees that we built with both the tissue and the cell-free DNA whole
exome. And we see there's higher concordance in these whole genome trees
compared to the whole exome trees from the only whole exome cell-free
DNA trees. In this case, we see these individual ESR1 clones
on both trees, which we didn't see in the whole
exome cell-free DNA.
So in conclusion, Ultima Genomics PPMseq assay provides a
highly sensitive, cost-efficient, and also adaptable whole
genome sequencing assay for cell-free DNA.
We can monitor tumor mutational burden and large clones in these processes.
And also we can identify a greater variety of resistance
mechanisms in response to treatment using whole genome sequencing, including
structural variants, copy number changes, the non-coding drivers, all of which
we're collecting more and more information about how they're really essential
to cancer and development. And also whole genome tissue and whole genome
sequencing cell-free DNA can provide the most comprehensive picture of a cancer
for research purposes. With that, I'd like
to acknowledge Gaddy and the Goetz Lab, the Broad Genomics
Platform for sequencing this data, and Ultima Genomics for partnering with us, and
also MGH with Dan Yerak and Doaa Goulan, and the
funding from the 2024 Krantz Awards. Thank you.
We'll open this up for questions.
Hello. Thanks for the great talk. I have a couple of questions about
the phylogenetic analysis and clonal decomposition,
basically. So I have looked at some of the autopsy data with
PhyLogicNDT, and it was whole exome sequencing
data. And we saw some discrepancies that did not match
with the original data. So I was wondering how was your experience with the
PhyLogicNDT, whether it
was much better with the whole genome sequencing.
So yeah, that's one question about the PhyLogicNDT.
And given that you have one sample with 120x
coverage, how
many clones, basically, can you
deconvolute from that?
To the first question. So yeah, whole genome sequencing with more mutations
per cluster, it does allow for more confidence in the
clustering, so you can get both more clusters and also a higher
confidence with the clusters when you have all sorts of non-coding
mutations as well to kind of better identify the clusters.
So also like repeatability, so the more times you run it, you're
more likely to get the same result as opposed to sometimes with whole exome
sequencing. If there are too few mutations to really resolve the clusters,
then mutations can almost kind of move around in between clusters if
there's not really a high confidence ability to cluster them.
And actually, in this case, in all of our patients, we sampled more than
one lesion. So, in some of the trees, one had seven.
The other tree I showed, there were actually three cell-free DNA samples.
So, having more than one sample additionally helps with the
clustering, because then you're able to, yeah, better track the mutations.
Thank you.
Another question in the back?
Yeah, just curious, if one only had access to Illumina
sequencing,
how deep would you have to go to get comparable results, or are there
things that you just cannot learn from the Illumina sequencing?
Yeah, I think if you can do duplex whole genome Illumina sequencing,
you'd probably be able to get similar results, I think
depending on the kind of duplex sequencing you'd use.
I think the strategy here, because Ultima's assay is
able to recover more of the duplex molecules, say if we sequence
to 100X, we'll get like 40X of the duplex.
Whereas I think some other assays, if you sequence to 100X, maybe you'll only
get like 10X of the duplex molecules.
So I think that is a factor. But I think in terms of
the genomics, the
assays,
the mutations won't be different.
I think you would probably have to sequence deeper because of
the lack of duplex recovery rate.
I see, and if you didn't have duplex, you just had regular ...
Yeah.
So do you just go deeper and you get the same-
I think then it becomes limited by the amount of DNA in
the tube.
Yeah.
Okay, thanks.
Mm-hmm.
Just as a final question, your phylogenetic analysis relies mostly on the
mutations. Are you using CNVs and copy number alterations
to refine that, or is it mostly CNV based?
Yeah.
Sure.
It's currently mostly CNV based, but definitely we can add copy number for sure.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. Okay, great. Thank you.
Okay, so for our final talk of the session,
bring it up.
Sofia Manjarrez is going to speak about colorectal cancer and the
microbiome. Come on up.
Thank you so much.
Great. So hi, everyone. Thanks for being here today.
My name is Sofia Manjarrez. I'm from the Velasquez-Villareal Lab
at City of Hope. I am currently a PhD student, and today I'll be talking to
you about artificial intelligence integrated analysis of the gut microbiome in
early and late onset colorectal cancer among populations at increased risk using
clinical, social, and social determinants data.
Excuse me, I said genomic and social determinants data.
First things first, I have no financial disclosures, so that's an easy slide.
And, to start, colorectal cancer, along with a lot of
different cancer types, are all commonly associated with age as a
pretty strong risk factor. And so over time, as
we've known that knowledge, improved our screening, we are able for
all ages to really get a better control.
However, when we start to stratify under the age of 50, what
we would consider early onset, we do see in recent years dramatic rises in
the rates of incidents as well as mortality for these individuals.
And when we, again, stratify one more time by racial and
ethnic groups, everyone is experiencing an increase in
early onset colorectal cancer, but specifically, Hispanic Latinos
are the group that has the highest increase in incidence rates from
2013 to 2022, which is 4%. And
so with that data, it gives us a
vital question and really a big push from our lab to
understand why is there an increase in this early onset colorectal cancer,
and also why specifically is the Hispanic Latino population impacted
this heavily.
And so when we talk about drivers of early onset colorectal cancer,
there are many potential drivers, but also ironing
out early onset drivers is really difficult.
When we sort of look at biology, there are certain characterized
differences, whether it's colon side presentation or specific
mutations that we associate with one or the other, but a lot remains in this middle
category that are diet and lifestyle and metabolic
conditions. And as well as when we consider health as a whole,
your biology is not the only thing that will feed into your risk.
We have to consider not only your biology, we have to consider
where you live, how you eat, the healthcare you have access to as a really
holistic look into your risk. And so because
of that, and our lab's
complex AI infrastructure to really help us ask these high level
questions, that has sort of pushed our work into seeing if
we can integrate our AI to be able to ask these really
multi-level complicated questions.
And ask what are the differences between early and late onset colorectal cancer,
and what is driving that earlier colorectal cancer
onset. So to get into methodology,
we have a cohort that comes from not only AACR
Project Genie, but also PECGS and USC COPEC, that
has about 2,715 samples. For these
samples, we are looking at whole exome sequencing, RNA sequencing,
social determinants of health data, and clinical variables.
And so not only are we looking atExcuse me.
Not only are we running traditional bioinformatic pipelines to do
fusion analysis, admixture analysis, copy number variation, but we are
also utilizing
our AI agents
through AI Hope to essentially work in parallel to us and also be running
analysis with us alongside. And then from this larger
cohort for us to do our microbiome work, we have a smaller
sample that is 23 fecal samples from Hispanic Latino CRC
patients in the LA area, and they were subject to 16S
rRNA sequencing.
And I'm going to go through this really quickly because this is the cohort as a
whole. But I do want to highlight, we do have
other work in this field that we've done from our lab that is
looking at specific genomic pathways and their connection to the Hispanic Latino
patients' response to medication and in different chemotherapy
regimens. Highlight Bridget, who's having her poster tomorrow,
and Paco, who had his poster yesterday, who take different looks at
this cohort. But for me specifically, my work is looking at that
microbial and integrating it into the data that we already have.
And so for that, we have to sort of go down to a little bit of a smaller
level for the sake of time and integration to look at these 10
individuals. And for our multi-omic data, our top figure...
Oh my gosh, excuse me. Our top figure, we have them split
into early and late onset throughout the whole thing.
But for our top part, we're looking at admixture analysis.
Essentially, when we think about
ancestry or genetic similarity, we compare
whole exome sequencing and compare with other
populations to sort of separate into what we call the five super populations.
And for Hispanic Latinos specifically, the super population that we're really
paying attention to are these red bars, which would comprise of Indigenous,
pulling from Peruvian in Lima, which would be
what we would consider closer to what we would consider the
Native people of Central and South America.
Essentially what we would think of as Hispanic Latino individuals, but we also know
these individuals are very admixed in general.
We also have down here our
traditional genomic mutations. We see some of the common drivers,
APC, PIK3CA, KRAS, popping up here,
but nothing that we can specifically highlight as early or late
onset. With our RNA fusion analysis, we do
actually have two for our
late onset group that are
clinically actionable fusions that have
potentially druggable targets,
up here and down here.
As well as we have our copy number variations.
We do see some little...
We do see some... Sorry. We do see some
patterns, but we see nothing that's specifically significant within
these groups to really characterize and differentiate them from each other.
And that's where we get to go into the microbial.
So our first
spot that we're looking at is essentially comparing early and late.
And right here, this is just essentially showing each person
is a column, and all of this is as a percentage showing the top
15 genus for each of these individuals.
Overall, when we look at early onset, when we compare alpha and beta diversity, we
do have a lowering in microbial diversity for this early onset group pretty
significantly. And then over here is essentially stretching that out, looking at
each individual genus. And for these, we have
three that are specifically significant, and that is Bacteroides is
highly enriched in the early onset.
Also Veillonella is also highly enriched, especially in this one
individual, for our early onset group.
And Segotella is one that we see more common in the late onset
group.
And on top of those microbial, we now get to do all the really fun parts where
we get to layer on our clinical and our social determinants of health.
For this, I decided to pick BMI, but we do have many versions of this as well.
Very similarly, we have what we would consider non-obese, which is a
BMI under 30, versus obese, which would be BMI of 30 and above.
There was no significant difference in the diversity of these groups, but we
did have two groups that were significantly separated.
That would be Faecalibacter bacterium would be
higher within...
Sorry. Veillonella was higher within the lower BMI group, and
Faecalibacter bacterium would be higher in the higher BMI group.
And so that sort of brings us to the AI
infrastructure of our lab.
Essentially, our multi-agent
AI infrastructure allows us to look at everything that we looked at sort of
individually and begin to integrate it all together.
So the microbial would be at the top, genetic similarity or admixture analysis,
mutation rates, clinical and social determinants of health, as well as our
multi-omic data on top of that. And we also have the
ability to, essentially because these are conversational agents, ask them a
question. So is there a difference between Fusobacterium and
Parvimonas in patients with colorectal cancer separated by onset?
And it is able to respond and give its own analyses and
run its own
questions alongside us and essentially answer back.
And so it's really cool. It's really fun to play with, but it's
also a really important tool for us to sort of take a precision medicine approach
in how we look at these patients and really leverage
every part of data that we have and get the biggest and best
picture of these individuals that we can.
And so to conclude, our analysis essentially shows decrease in microbial
diversity in early onset is one of those major things that we can look at.
But there are also differences when we start to stratify down.
Obviously, more work needs to be done with that because we also need to find
outAgain, the ways to characterize those groups better.
But the integration with the help of AI is really helping us do that faster,
efficiently, and to a really high standard.
But these differences within the microbiome could provide more insight into that
contribution to early onset, but we are working on larger comparative studies to
better understand risks for this high-risk population.
And just to acknowledge everyone, I want to thank my lab, the Velasquez-Villareal
Lab. All of you are great. Thank you for supporting me through my first AACR.
Our funding sources, Microbiome Core at City of Hope, and my entire Department of
Integrative Translational Sciences. Thank you for being here.
And yeah, thank you for listening.
Okay. We'll open this up to questions.
One here.
Thank you very much. Great talk. My name's Dori Abelman from the Broad.
I'm very curious about the AI infrastructure that you mentioned in your lab.
Is that, for example, an instance of cloud code that you're running through
GitHub Copilot that has access to a folder with all the data?
So
as far as I'm aware, I don't
know 100% of the specifics. I know we have multiple
agents that are run through us. I know it's not like it's under
a different umbrella. It is our
in-house AI, essentially, if that's part of your question.
We can definitely talk more about the specifics as well, if you want to come by
after, because I'm not 100% sure on all of them, but I'll be able to point
you to the people who do.
Thank you.
Great.
What's your strategy for increasing the sample size?
Because it's small.
It is small. I think a big part of that is also we're working with
a really specialized group, and so of course, increasing sample size is
important, not only for representation, but also visibility.
We do have plans in place to start working on increasing that
sample size. Also with the fecal samples
specifically,
we're trying to work with our institution and see if we're able to make that
happen. But, yeah, they're definitely difficult samples to get, which is
unfortunate, but really important data to get from them.
Great. Another question.
Yes. Thank you for your presentation, and thank you to Dr. Villareal and the lab.
I know he likes Project Genie quite a bit and presents quite a bit on it.
So when we're talking about this in the context of disparities, one question I
had for you is, have you heard of the Hispanic
paradox? Are you familiar with that concept?
So I think I've heard of it, and I think I've heard of it in a different way, if
you could explain it to me.
Yeah. So it's a
well-established paradox. If you look at Hispanics who have
migrated to America, they actually have healthier outcomes
traditionally than others, which is when you're comparing across
socioeconomic status, like Black, they actually
supersede even whites that might be of wealthier economic status as
well. So it's been a paradox that's been known for a while.
I'm actually wondering, with that increase in colorectal cancer, since we are
seeing it across all races, but the spike in that, it might be
due to generational differences.
So you're now having second-generational Hispanics here in America.
And I don't know if you guys consider that, but it's something that if you're going
to think about it in the context of social determinants of health, it's something
that you'll likely want to stratify by. But I don't know.
I know there's several from your lab here, but just a thought.
Yeah. No, I definitely agree with you.
I've had talks with a couple other people talking about the generational
difference, and so it's definitely something I think we need to look into and
really understand, because like you said, it's not just Hispanic,
Latino, but it is kind of everyone.
Yeah.
Yeah, I want to add. This is basically a project from the new
sub-project we have. So one of the big points is
we have already aiming 500 samples and all this
using the whole exome sequencing, RNA-Seq, spatial
transcriptomics, and different high-definition spatial proteomics.
One of the main points is in microbiome.
We have the 250 samples. It's like
presentation of the 23 at 10 at some point.
But yeah, so we have different sub-stratifications.
And one of the main points in the sub-stratification is that we categorize
Hispanic, Latino in East L.A. area.
So this is a very homogeneous population that we know
will come to a cancer center at USC and City of Hope, and we
get to the
basically obtain of the samples and then get all the social
determinants of health according with the PCGS.
That is basically establishing what is health literacy, what is
obesity, what is understanding our limits, and
basically, this is a partnership with different universities, including
Harvard University, Dana-Farber,
NYU. And so one of the important points also is
to understand that all this stratification is helping us to
understand this paradox. And another point is the time
that when we check a different generation, the ancestry analysis,
it changed through parents to the second
generation. So we are looking for these differences, and I
think that's another important point.
Now, for the Broad Institute, so this is local AI.
We're building based on Llama models.
So this is basically we build from scratch, so we don't pay a single
penny to ChatGPT or any other one. So this is HIPAA-protected,
genome-protected. So the ways we get inside our
infrastructure, we have a different AI agents for
different pathway analysis and for each of the multi-omics,
including the microbiome. All this is our ecosystem, so agents connect each
other, start to getting information.
None of this is related with a website, so this is a closed system.
And basically, we get a lot of
increase in the super computational resources through Amazon if we need
increased double encryption to get a terabyte-level
analysis. So that's basically the AI hub, yeah.
And we have around 30 publications on that, so it's a lot of
technical details and hope to create in-house AI
system created by biostatistician or physician
scientists running the parameters by themselves instead of going
to engineers outside the lab. So thanks so much.
Okay. So with that, just we'll wrap it up.
I'll just echo
Todd's statement at the beginning.
I think a lot of the projects benefited from data sharing.
So I think as we're moving forward to new data types, it's not
clear that Genie's going to be able to get those new data types.
So we need to come up with some new organizations and new efforts to make sure
microbiome, whole genome,
novel genomic subtypes, or types of data are shared.
So
hope to see that at future AACR meetings, and thanks for coming. So thank you.